you know we got some great guests
tonight I think I think the audience the
students was stunned by the caliber of
our guests tonight yeah they were
stunned I think they're like as most is
this way oh is this Late Night with
Conan O'Brien where is Eddie Munster you
know we found him ladies and gentlemen
you know they're just they were shocked
well you know III have to say and
defending our show we do especially in
the last year so we get a lot of great
guests on this show now we really do
look at tonight's guests for example as
I mentioned top quality guests that you
see on any program but sometimes we got
to be honest we get some guests that
really don't work out we do and you got
to come clean on this yeah some of them
really sucked yeah that's another more
blunt way of saying yeah yeah that's
well I mean I was I was panicking here
yeah but we do we get we get some guests
sometimes and you try and control
everything in this business but you get
some guests on you think it's gonna be
good and then it just goes awry and it's
just some bad TV well if nothing else we
own up to our mistakes here on the show
we do we're very honest we celebrate
them yeah we celebrate we hug yeah and
well tonight we thought we'd take just a
minute to remember some of those
unpleasant but we think very memorable
moments in a segment that we call guests
will never have back
[Applause]
all right now I remember you know
looking back we were looking through the
files just find someone if you remember
this guy we had a musician Pete Chandler
on the show not too long ago and he
builds himself as the world's loudest
trumpet player and we thought we got to
hear that that'll be really cool but his
appearance frankly didn't really go that
well take a look now you claim to be the
world's loudest trumpet player that's
right my sound has been measured at over
150 decibels care to give us a
demonstration sure you might want to
cover your ears
[Applause]
[Music]
I thought that guy made a little too
much of it you know I know
like what something goes wrong just
cover it and keep going right we had dr.
Joyce brothers on after him he screamed
through her whole interview yeah you
couldn't hear her yeah all right very
sad now we thought it might be nice to
have Linda Stenson on the show I'll tell
you who she is she's a local
self-defense instructor and we figured
we could you know we could have her on
she could give us a demonstration that
would be both fun and informative on
self-defense and that also just didn't
didn't really work out take a look so
this is stuff that anyone can use to
protect themselves absolutely both men
and women can learn these simple impact
basic moves
terrific what's a sea demonstration okay
great so let's say someone is going to
approach me from the front all right
he'll palm okay just right up and under
that was great that was terrific great
let me let me try that okay okay
someone's coming towards me I'm out on
the street and then just real calm right
I'm sorry I didn't I didn't mean to hurt
you what what did she do you weren't
supposed to hurt
[Applause]
now I blacked out after five minutes of
beating but I could have sworn I heard
your voice over in the corner saying get
him well I've been the victim of your
superhuman strength had up coming you
didn't really jump into my defense there
I don't remember this next guy but his
name Malphite for real baseball fans
will know right it's Mel Pfeiffer Mel
play professional baseball back in the
20s and 30s we thought he'd be a
fascinating guy to talk to you know he'd
know all the legends well he was
fascinating just not in the way that we
expected watch I got to say it's very
exciting to have you I mean you were on
the Yankees from 1923 to 1934 that's
right so you must have played with some
of the all-time greats
whoa Lou Gehrig Babe Ruth tabe Ruth
that's incredible tell me what was he
like loss well God you know he may have
been a hard-drinking slob to the press
but once you got him into bed it was a
busy death but got him into bed yeah Lou
Gary he was rough he'd give you a hard
time left one besides he was into
threesomes foursomes not my style
I'm sorry let me get this straight
you're saying that Lou Gehrig and Babe
Ruth were gay oh sure
hardy bastards toefl they all were at
that time
Ty Cobb Jimmy Fox called Hubble and I've
bagged every one of them we'll be back
that's when I wish we hadn't looked back
on all right well you know I was I gotta
say speaking of sports I was really
excited when we booked UCLA quarterback
Doug Kavanagh to be on the program
because it was just so after he won the
Heisman Trophy and this guy was hot at
the time so we thought this gonna be a
great segment but frankly he turned out
to be a huge disappointment you'll see
okay so tell me what do we do okay this
is just a basic accuracy drill all I got
to do is put the ball through the tire
okay this sounds fun why don't you go
first demonstrate for us all right
hey all right that's pretty good at some
arm you got there all right now my turn
now and I'll just try it right foot it
up a little high but close so huh again
okay well there you go and see how that
mine goes high I guess which is again
look I really don't think oh you're not
paid to think I'll do the thinking here
now you're gonna do is to get it right
go you know I don't have to listen to
you you are a wool wimp roll the bull
you're crazy
throw the damn ball I'm not what hey not
gonna what
you're not gonna what you're sick guy
hey watch it
that was the second time I heard
off-camera your voice get him
see I don't think that he should be
included in this segment the living tar
out of me on TV cooking segments or
something that will get him back don't
worry now finally the last guy there's
this guy David Preston he's the curator
at the Central Park Zoo I'd heard a lot
about this guy and I was really looking
forward to meeting him and having his
animals on and everything but
unfortunately we didn't know he had a
bit of an allergy problem take a look so
what have you got for us today
ok Coenen today I brought a Mongolian
mountain goat her name's Mary Ann now
these animals are indigenous to East
excuse me they're indigenous to East
Asia also remote remote
oh crap are you okay you know what I'm
pretty good you know what we're gonna do
was gonna move on okay it's a good idea
we've got another animal here this is
exciting this here is a baby P phone
this is a P file that's interesting yeah
now they are look at that yeah they're
natively uh excuse me but they are you
okay yeah sure I'm pretty good maybe
we'll just get to why I'm here really
this next okay moving on that's good
thanks Andy God you are you sure you're
at your phone yes
this here is a silk it's a silky chick
okay I don't I don't think this is
working this is don't you know we're
gonna hair okay I think what we're gonna
we're gonna get we're gonna get you a
doctor okay this is strange ever name's
Karen I don't care we're going to a
brainer now yeah just your ash all right
we gotta go
we'll be right back all right look just
just I can't pretty pony yeah I think
you're here free he's dying
sure someone would you get a doctor I'm
a doctor I can breathe
well
none other guess we won't have that well
anyway we thought we should have up to
that yeah I have a feeling tonight will
go a little better than yes I think so
alright we're gonna take a little break
when we come back Penny Marshall is
going to be with us don't want to miss
her I stick around with you